there's this channel like that's i don't
know why it gives me report of the week
vibes it totally
might be an insult i don't know but it's
called project farm right all he does is
just review like
engine oil and like like and he'll like
review like different tapes
there is truly a channel for everything
yeah and he's just so
like there was a video and he reviews
like flex tape gorilla tape and compares
them all
and like i don't give a [ __ ] about any
of this but he's so passionate about
reviewing these things
and he's so genuine yeah what's that
[ __ ] channel that reviews all of the
locks
lockpick lawyer yeah i love it as well i
[ __ ] like
his like i i feel like he's like loki
one of the funniest characters
i love it indestructible lock in the
title
20 second video it's like oh okay all
right he's just gonna pick this so
lock picking lawyer is a lawyer and his
whole channel he's like a lock-picking
expert
yeah and he's he just it's so funny
because he's built up so many in-jokes
because he's just yeah he's insane at
picking locks yeah and he
and like all his delivery is so dry yeah
he's like he's got like the driest
delivery you can ever imagine but that's
why
every time he makes a joke it just hits
everything that was like yeah there was
a
video that he made for april fools that
was uh breaking into my
backyard it was like ex-girlfriend right
yeah
yeah oh it was so funny it was so funny
and like she didn't let me in the front
door so i guess i have to go in through
the back
yeah and then there was like rust on the
key that he actually put things
i've got to get rid of the brown residue
he's got to make sure the hole is like
well lubricated so he can uh fit in the
key and everything and then
i love that like normally anyone else
this would be like this would be like
third grade humor but he's like the way
he delivers it what's the driver man
i think one of my favorite video of his
was like when uh
i can't remember the exact video name
but it was like some guy who had sent
him
a uh a lock that he tried to get picked
by like a professional lock picker
it was impossible yeah he said it was
impossible but i saw this one guy on
youtube do it
and he just [ __ ] destroys this lock
in seconds
like it's like if you can do it in less
than two minutes i think the challenge
was he did it in like 10 seconds
like he just he sees a lock and it's
already picked when he picked it up like
i don't know how this man does
he's just hockey man he's just like he
like unlocks it
and it's the best part is there's
there's no [ __ ] to these videos
there's no arrogance he's just he's
someone he doesn't need to flex
you know he's just really funny he's
just a really good minimal intro
they're all three minutes long but you
get exactly what you want you normally
end up like laughing or giggling like
it's just such
i love these like non-bullshit channels
like um like i like daily dose of
internet as well
because it's it's just it's just no
[ __ ] here's just like here's just
like
reddit top page you know with no filler
you know
what i've seen on twitter such a nice
dude as well yeah yeah exactly